[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat avec un mais côté
thibault inox bon gentil beau bonjour
auriol et cette semaine notre invité est
elle à faucillon bonjour je vous
remercie d'être avec nous vous êtes
député communiste des hauts-de-seine et
dans l'actualité parlementaire cette
semaine il ya d'abord cette réponse du
sénat au gilet jaune la majorité les
républicains a voté la suppression de la
hausse des taxes sur les carburants
l'exécutif lui garde le cap et
confirment celles de hausse au 1er
janvier le président de la république
évoque cependant la possibilité de la
moduler en fonction des prix du baril en
2019 une grande concertation est aussi
lancé le premier ministre a reçu des
parlementaires à matignon jeudi des
permanences saccagé des députés de la
majorité et menacés parfois jusqu'à leur
domicile
intimidations insultes c'est la face
sombre du mouvement des gilet jaune
elle a été dénoncé cette semaine à
l'assemblée par son président richard
ferrand enfin nous reviendrons sur cette
passe d'armes au sénat entre gérald
darmanin et les sénateurs les sénateurs
qui ont été jusqu'à lui et le ministre
des comptes publics cette semaine après
un tweet de ce dernier qui a suscité
leur colère
et on commence cette semaine avec
l'examen du budget au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chambre haute qui poursuit son
marathon budgétaire et cette semaine il
a pris une tournure très politique comme
une réponse aux critiques qui sont
faites au gouvernement le sénat a voté
le gel de la hausse des taxes sur le
carburant mais aussi débattu de la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
un résumé des débats avec héloïse
grégoire et adrien de vallées alors que
la colère des gilets jaunes grogne
partout en france
lundi le sénat a décidé de bousculer
l'ordre du jour comme pour répondre au
mouvement
la haute-assemblée des sites le gel de
la hausse des prix du carburant jusqu'en
certains très excité demande à être
considéré cet amendement est un
amendement de considération et d' écoute
de nos compatriotes il ne remet pas en
cause l'avenir d'une énergie moins
carbonée mais il temporise sur un tout
autre sujet mardi les sénateurs ont
supprimé un amendement qui proposait un
crédit d'impôt au foyer qui accueillait
des migrants chez eux aussi cet
amendement d'un député la république en
marche l'avait déposée à l'assemblée
mais ni la droite du sénat ni le
gouvernement n'en voulait comment ils
sont choisis qui décide
dans quel cadre le geste est généreux la
pratique me paraît pour le moins
compliqué mercredi la gauche du sénat a
tenté de restaurer l'impôt sur la
fortune
le débat de 2017 si rejouer dans
l'hémicycle communistes et socialistes
se sont heurtés à l'opposition de la
majorité aient l'air donc je ne saurais
trop inviter nos collègues républicains
à soutenir cet amendement vous marquerez
l'histoire pour l'éternité suppression
des taxes carburant rétablissement dsf
tout le monde vous applaudir est je vous
invite à la faute et ce serait une folie
de le rétablir
si la france est le seul pays à avoir
une taxation ou quasiment le seul pays à
avoir une taxation de dd des capitaux et
bien les jambes iront ailleurs
enfin jeudi les sénateurs ont adopté une
série d'amendements qui réduit la taxe
sur la valeur ajoutée des produits de
première nécessité comme les couches et
produits pour l'incontinence urinaire
par exemple sont un produit de première
nécessité qui pour moi mon mérite
l'application du taux de tva à 5,5 au
lieu de 20%
ils sortent donc juste de l'étendre aux
protections hygiéniques pour les
personnes âgées par principe d'égalité
la réduction de la tva sur les
croquettes pour chien n'a en revanche
pas été adopté par les sénateurs est la
faucille ont la majorité les
républicains donc voté la suppression de
la hausse de la taxe sur les carburants
vous êtes d'accord avec elle sur ce
point déjà je trouvais assez formidable
de pouvoir discuter grand public du
budget souvent c'est ça échappe aux
citoyens de ce pays c'est un débat
extrêmement opaque
d'ailleurs même souvent pour les
nouveaux députés et donc je trouve que
pouvoir avoir quelque part cet examen en
direct depuis une mobilisation
importante une colère qui s'exprime
ça pourrait être y compris pour les
sénateurs le moment de réponse
extrêmement concrètes immédiates à cette
colère qui s'exprime dans le pays
moi je suis évidemment pour un moratoire
l'arrêt de cette taxe sur les carburants
le le gel nous on prend décembre 2017
pour ce que c'était un moment je le
crois plus favorable la question c'est
que vous avez vu mon collègue sénateur
communiste propose dans un même temps la
de rétablir lisf qui fait partie
d'ailleurs des revendications souvent
qu'on voit sur les points de
mobilisation des gilet jaune qui disent
rendez lisf d'abord je crois que c'est
extrêmement important pour marquer une
réponse d'égalité parce qu'il ya cette
revendication la extrêmement forte qui
s'exprime dans les mobilisations et dans
la colère qui dépasse d'ailleurs que ce
soit ceux qui portent des gilets ou qui
n'en portent pas il ya une colère que je
suis au régime très inquiet manuel m'a
fortement cette réforme de l'aef
we ll est elle est un marqueur elle
n'est pas la seule
tout le reste on a découlé elle montre à
la fois une réponse immédiate à ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas besoin lisf y avait pas
de demande de la part des plus riches
mais il ya une réponse immédiate dans un
même temps on avait vu l'an dern
et les apl la csg qui avait déjà
commencé a suscité de la colère mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens de ce
pays les prouve dans leur chair ils en
subissent directement les conséquences
alors on a parlé de la goutte d en
descend ce qu'a fait déborder le vase
avec cette taxe sur les câbles carburant
mais on voit bien que les revendications
sont ceux bien bien plus large on a vu
une première plateforme sortir hier avec
une demande de hausse des salaires des
bas salaires une demande de hausse des
pensions mais aussi on l'a vu des
revendications disons le écologiques qui
sont présentes dans les revendications
des plateformes et qui me disait la
colère et profonde à les largesses qu'un
moratoire c'est suffisant qu'est-ce
qu'il faut apporter comme réponse à ces
gilet jaune assez français ce que ce que
je crois c'est que c'est moi je vais
parler de révolution en tout cas de
bouleversement de deux modèles je prends
le temps de m'expliquer là dessus je
crois que la révolution écologique elle
est urgente nécessaire et que d'ailleurs
les citoyens de notre pays
la ressentent extrêmement profondément
au labo la révolution la colère des
gilet jaune aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
anti urgence écologique
il y en a même qui ont appelé à aller
marcher le 8 décembre avec celles et
ceux qui manifesteront pour le climat
une révolution écologique c'est un
changement de modèle aujourd'hui on est
sur un modèle qui en permanence favorise
les plus puissants les plus riches qui
autorise à totale d'importer de l'huile
de palme qui autorise dans les forêts en
guyane au côté de la montagne d'or voilà
un système qui ne peut répondre à
l'urgence écologique qui est on est
presque en retard sur la réponse aux
urgences
mais cette révolution écologique elle ne
se fera pas sans justice sociale c'est
impossible quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
qu'à cette taxe sur les sur les
carburants qui touche les mêmes les
personnes de la même manière celui qui a
ou celle qui à 700 euros par mois ou
celui quant à 8000 alors même que ce
sont les plus riches qui y compris ont
le plus la plus lourde empreinte carbone
il ya un graphique assez clair
c'est les plus riches qui ont
l'empreinte carbone qui font le plus de
kilomètres souvent avec les plus grosses
voitures parfois certaines extrêmement
polluante et eux ça leur coûte pas grand
chose dans le porte monnaie alors que
quand vous avez 700 euros par mois et
qui à 30 euros de plus sur votre plein
et que en plus la seule réponse
gouvernementale c'est de vous expliquer
qu'il faut changer de voiture vous
comprenez que il ya du mépris
donc oui lisf c'est un marqueur à la
fois profondément inégalitaire en termes
de mesures concrètes mais aussi en terme
de mépris mais c'est parce qu'il ya une
parce que je finis
excusez moi je termine parce que aussi
vous avez entendu que la le gouvernement
le président de la république se donne
trois mois pour des réponses à prévenir
alors justement un exécutif a décidé de
lancer à la grande consultation de
terrain dont vous parlez sur la
transition écologique et pour la
préparer edouard philippe a reçu jeudi à
matignon les membres du conseil national
de la transition écologique dont des
parlementaires
nous allons écouter l'un d'eux jean
françois husson et sénateurs les
républicains de meurthe et moselle au
micro de jérôme rabier ce que j'ai
entendu mardi me fait craindre le pire
le présent république s'exprime devant
un parterre d'élus et de responsables
avec un bandeau derrière lui qui dit
changement semble or il dit je ne change
pas d'avis il faut pas chercher la
vérité et je ne change pas de cap
c'est complètement contradictoire donc
évidemment il faut partir sur des bases
ouverte et il faut poser les armes est
la faucille on vous y croyez à cette
grande concertation est ce que c'est pas
juste une manière pour l'exécutif de
gagner du temps écoutez je moi je sors
d'un d'un congrès donc je vais pas vous
citer la phrase de clemenceau mais on a
l'habitude dans ce type d'exercice
d'expliquer quand il ya un problème on
la met dans une commission et que
généralement ce problème est assez vite
assez vite enterré est pas traitée mais
surtout je le redis le fait de ceux
d'expliquer que alors même qu'il ya des
revendications extrêmement concrètes
on se donne trois mois pour y répondre
vous comprenez que ça dit la la surdité
à l'urgence et aux demandes quand vous
avez 25 % des ménages aujourd'hui
compper de basculer dans la pauvreté
dans les cinq ans à venir
vous rendez compte l'urgence vitale
qu'ils ressentent face aux mesures qui
sont qui sont attendus hausse du smic
hausse des dépenses ion il ya tout un
tas de mesures aujourd'hui il ya celle
évidemment sur les carburants
mais la question du pouvoir d'achat mais
pas seulement celle tout simplement
d'avoir un salaire digne
vous avez le premier ministre qu'est ce
que sur une chaîne concurrente qui
explique la question c'est pas
d'augmenter le smic c'est que le travail
travail paie mais quelle absurdité de
cette phrase
enfin vous justement ces gens là
travaillent veulent être à la fois
respectée considérée mais ya pas que des
marques de considérations abstraites
ils ont besoin d'une considération
extrêmement concrètes et ils ont besoin
de vivre tout simplement
on a entendu très nombreuses phrases que
moi j'ai trouvé extrêmement parlante de
gens qui disent on peut plus en aller au
restaurant on peut plus offrir des
cadeaux à nos mômes à noël des choses
qui font que la vie est agréable aussi
qu'elle n'est pas toujours en mode
survie
et là les gens sont en mode sur un mot
juste pour finir puisqu'on a vu de leur
fils est perçue des parlementaires mais
aussi des élus locaux des syndicats des
associations est ce que cette séquence a
montré l'utilité des corps
intermédiaires
oui je crois d'ailleurs c'était assez
drôle de noter le gouvernement qui
expliquait que le mouvement des gilet
jaune n'était pas assez organisés que il
n'était pas assez démocratique que il y
avait des débordements alors même qu'
ils font partie et je peux accuser
également les gouvernements précédents
d'avoir fait un travail de sape des
corps intermédiaires d'avoir en
permanence expliqué leur inutilité leur
non représentativité d'avoir mis des
bâtons dans les roues à 7 à tout à tous
ces corps intermédiaires donc je crois
que le gouvernement se rend compte à
quel point ces corps intermédiaires sont
utiles et y compris dans les
convergences qui vont s'exprimer entre
syndicats associations mouvements déjà
existants je crois qu'il ya une sorte de
convergence utile qui va se faire dans
les prochains jours allez on en vient
notre deuxième thème ces menaces reçues
par certains députés de la majorité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des menaces dénoncé par le président de
l'assemblée richard ferrand mardi elles
se sont multipliées envers certains un
député de la majorité depuis le
mouvement le début du mouvement des
gilet jaune c'est le cas de la députée
mireille robert de la république en
marche dans la propriété a été envahie
par une quarantaine de personnes
encagoulés et casqués ses collègues lui
ont affiché leur soutien
mais ce cas n'est pas isolé les députés
s'inquiètent de ce climat délétère mas
était vraiment sous les applaudissements
de ses collègues
la député de l'aude mireille robert
prend la parole après l'intrusion chez
elle de dizaines de gilet jaune
encagoulés pas de revendication juste de
l'intimidation pour le moins inquiétante
dans notre république vous en
conviendrez c'est intolérable est pour
le moins inquiétant occuper le domicile
du député voir s'introduire chez lui ce
genre d'action se répète sur les réseaux
sociaux les adresses personnelles
circulent avec un message clair menacer
directement le député
une situation inédite pour les élus de
la majorité qui dénonce ce genre de
pratiques
lorsqu'ils menacent de monsieur de
m'empêcher de sortir chez moi je ne
discute pas je ne discute pas parce
qu'on s'en prend la personne privée à
son domicile à sa famille ce député de
gironde a lui aussi été pris pour cible
en rentrant dans sa circonscription il
découvre sur le mur de sa maison
ce tag ce n'est pas la démocratie de la
rue la démocratie c'est au parlement
c'est à l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes là
bien ancré sur nos territoires et nous
faisons remonter donc au gouvernement ce
qui ne va pas les points de crispation
mais il faut nous laisser travailler
olivier gaillard député du gard a quant
à lui reçu des menaces de mort c'est une
des photos qui a circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux sur accueillait le moi car mon
nom et celui prisoner république à dos
et un cercueil qui ne croit d'abord
c'est le choc
vient ensuite la remise en question
aller sur le terrain pour dialoguer
aujourd'hui il faut être clair nous
sommes inaudible et qu'elle jeudi nous
la classe politique est inaudible
donc à partir de là moi je vais
continuer à travailler mais il faut que
l'on ne sont plus précis dans nos
actions à venir
au total une vingtaine de députés de la
majorité mais aussi un élu les
républicains ont subi ces attaques
ils sont nombreux à avoir porté plainte
les atteintes à la vie privée et sont
passibles de trois ans d'emprisonnement
et de 45000 euros damende elsa faucillon
est ce que vous êtes inquiète vous même
de cette violence envers les élus est ce
que vous dites ça va trop loin elle est
compliquée cette question pain
évidemment on condamne les violences
qu'ont lieu d' atteinte à la personne
elles sont d'ailleurs condamnable par la
loi donc c'est sarah vient d'en rajouter
il faut que ça puisse aller jusqu'au
bout y compris à une partie importante
des gilet jaune qui qui condamne les
débordements l'excès de violence moi
j'ai pas de conseil à donner aux élus de
la majorité jeu il y en a certains par
exemple qu'ils reçoivent dans leur
permanence des délégations de gilet
jaune pour pouvoir s'exprimer je crois
que c'est important de pouvoir le faire
y compris quand il ya un député qui dit
la démocratie de la rue mais quelle
vision il a de la démocratie si elles se
déroulent pas aussi dans la rue il n'est
pas le seul à pouvoir participer à la à
la démocratie et puis il faut voir aussi
que et je veux pointer personne en
particulier mais mais il ya des députés
qui y compris dans leurs prises de
parole ont été particulièrement
méprisant
je me souviens de certaines phrases
venons expliqué ils vont pas pleurer
pour 5 euros par exemple au moment de la
baisse des appels ou celles et ceux qui
vantait les mérites des cocktails à
l'assemblée je pense qu'il faut être en
capacité au vu de la défiance au vu d'un
gouvernement qui ne répondent pas très
concrètement à pouvoir ouvrir tous les
espaces de débat y compris pour des
députés de la majorité qui défendent ce
gouvernement moi je crois qu'un député
il doit d'abord défendre les gens les
habitants de sa circonscription avant de
défendre le gouvernement même quand il
est de la majorité car justement mon
avis ketkeo centre pour la majorité mais
mais y compris évidemment je ne m'
extrait pas de ça en tant que député
d'opposition j'ai besoin également de me
sentir au plus près de ses attentes et
de ses revendications delà des
débordements est ce que vous diriez
justement que la majorité la république
en marche vers une forme de déconnexion
avec les français avec les territoires
notamment oui après je suis pas pour
qu'elle la paye au prix cher c'est à
dire au prix des violences mais oui je
crois qu'elle elle paye elle paye du
mépris elle paye paye le fait de
voiliers cette réponse qui vient à dire
changer de voiture c'est tellement à
côté de la plaque et donc évidemment il
ya à la fois l'absence de réponse le
refus la surdité face aux urgences
et puis il ya une façon de une façon de
s'exprimer qui montre à la fois de la
déconnexion mais je dirais aussi
moi j'ai entendu des phrases jugeant les
gilet jaune où il y avait un peu le
mépris de la centralité presque vu paris
face à ceux entendus des choses comme
les beaufs
enfin voila on avait l'impression qu'il
y avait les gueux qui étaient dans la
rue et puis et puis les autres qui
décide et qui leur expliquer ce qui
était bon pour eux donc c'est ça aussi
l'idée de n'ya pas de démocratie de la
russie d'antiparlementarisme aussi qui
est exprimé par ce mouvement il
revendique ne s'invente alors que les
doléances la suppression du sénat
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il est pas
nouveau cet antiparlementarisme il est
nourri depuis un certain nombre de temps
nourri à la fois parce que il ya eu la
déconnexion des réponses qui ne
correspondaient pas aux besoins des
français la suppression de service
public en masse et puis aussi je dirais
pas d excès mais carrément un dévoiement
de ce que doit être le parlementaire
quand il ya eu des affaires à la fois de
corruption d'abus de biens sociaux en
masse et il y en a eu un paquet donc ça
l'antiparlementarisme il se nourrit
aussi je crois que certains parfois aux
thèses un peu complotistes il ya les
deux versants la question c'est
forcément dans la période je crois que
les députés de la majorité n'êtes pas à
faire machine arrière
on va poursuivre cette semaine marquée
par de vives tensions entre gérald
darmanin et le sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est parti d'un tweet publié par le
ministre des comptes publics il
stigmatisait un amendement sur la
fiscalité des élus votée à l'unanimité
par le sénat
colère des sénateurs qui suspende la
séance sans retirer son tweet gérald
darmanin a fini par faire amende
honorable sous les huées des sénateurs
michael spitzberg vous raconte cette
séquence mouvementée la bronca et le mea
culpa
gérald darmanin elle était attendue de
pied ferme par la majorité sénatoriale
lors des questions au gouvernement mardi
sous les huées le ministre de l'action
et des comptes publics a fait amende
honorable
il est vrai que au lieu de faire des
tweets il vaut mieux dire en face les
choses vous avez raison
épilogue d'un psychodrame parlementaire
vendredi dernier en pleine discussion
sur le budget 2010 9 au sénat le
ministre absent de l'hémicycle publié un
tweet en guise de réponse à l'adoption
d'un amendement sur l'imposition des
élus locaux à l'initiative des
républicains le sénat vient de voter une
augmentation de 125% de la déduction
fiscale des élus qui revient à les
exonérer d'impôt jusqu'à 1500 euros par
mois sur leurs indemnités
je m'y opposerai évidemment en seconde
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
résultat la majorité sénatoriale de
droite voit rouge et décide de suspendre
ses travaux
senna paralysé sur la question de la
défense des petits et du c'était une
injustice de fait avec le nouveau
prélèvement à la source qui fait que les
indemnités qu'ils ne sont pas un salaire
sont maintenant où seront maintenant
considéré comme s'ajoutant aux revenus
de tels individus il ait jamais été dans
l'intention du sénat de faire un cadeau
fiscal comme ça à qui que ce soit on
veut corriger une situation qui a été
créée par l'anticipation du prélèvement
à la source c'est ça le sujet il ya un
vrai débat le gouvernement on est
d'accord il ya un sujet on
le traité tout est réglé
après intervention du premier ministre
edouard philippe auprès du président du
sénat gérard larcher
la discussion sur le budget 2010 9
reprend en début de semaine et un accord
sur l'amendement polémique est entérinée
fin de l'histoire ou presque à la
reprise des débats la droite sénatoriale
a tenu à envoyer un message au
gouvernement avec un amendement teinté
de jaune contre la hausse de la taxe sur
le carburant en janvier prochain est à
noter que dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi le sénat a voté avec l'appui du
gouvernement un amendement a rectifié
visant spécifiquement les élus des
petites communes
alors l info si on vous députés quel
regard avez vous porté sur ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine au sénat est ce que
le tweet de gérald darmanin était
opportun a obtenu une grosse erreur de
sa part est une diversion politicienne
de sa part à la fois pour essayer de
tourner l'attention vers les sénateurs
ou sénatrice plutôt que vers les
demandes de réponse dès gilet jaune
je crois aussi et surtout peut-être
comme une réponse à sa mauvaise phrase
sur les frais de restaurant où les
restaurants à moins de 200 euros
donc dans grosse erreur de la part de
gérald darmanin et voilà pour cette
passe d'armes au sénat l'assemblée s'est
aussi penché cette semaine sur un autre
bras de fer celui qui oppose les parents
et les enfants
au terme de ville débat les députés ont
adopté une proposition du groupe modem
interdisant l'usagé des violences
éducatives ordinaires fessées gifles et
toute forme de correction physique
seront bientôt prohibé dans le droit
français le texte à ce stade ne prévoit
cependant pas de sanction et aura donc
une portée essentiellement symbolique
est la faucille on vous féliciter de
cette adoption
oui j'étais cosignataires à la base de
cette proposition de loi qu'a toujours
homme était un peu ridiculisé y compris
dans les médias comme la loi anti fessée
je crois pas qu'elle est juste une
valeur symbolique en revanche bien sûr
elle n'est pas elle ne relève pas du
pénal
ce qui relève du pénal c'est la
maltraitance c'est les coups répétés
fort etc et donc il ya déjà le penalty
qui se charge de ça l'idée c'est de
pouvoir installer un principe
le principe c'est que éduqués ne se fait
pas par la violence
et donc ça ça permet également à l'or il
ya la phrase qui sera dit lors des
mariages par exemple mais y compris pour
les acteurs les actrices de l'éducation
qui sont ou celles et ceux qui sont dans
le secteur de la santé ou du social
pouvoir s'appuyer sur ce texte pour en
faire un principe
après il reste maintenant à permettre
des moyens pour l'aide à la parentalité
je pense aux pmi aux associations qui se
charge de ça mais je crois aussi
travaillé un peu mieux à l'égalité homme
femme et à la coparentalité
c'est je crois des mesures qui
permettront sa real application mais
qu'elle portera ce texte il n'y a pas de
sanctions finalement l'idée c'est de
pouvoir énoncé un principe clair qui dit
aujourd'hui que un geste humiliant une
parole extrêmement agressive
ce n'est pas à la fois sa n'éduque pas
bien enfin on a tous remarqué je crois
que ce n'était pas la meilleure manière
pour pour se faire entendre
et puis ensuite je crois que ça permet
quand un pédiatre par exemple quand une
puéricultrice dit cela on n'est pas sur
un jugement moral quand il dit il faut
pas frapper un enfant ce n'est plus un
jugement moral qui répondra une coutume
c'est un principe qui permet d'expliquer
que ce n'est pas comme ça que nous
éduquons après je le rappelle chacun
ensuite éduquer son enfant comme il le
souhaite selon les valeurs qu'ils
souhaitent y a pas de prescription sur
le type d'éducation à donner mais mais
mais notons quand même que je crois
chacun et chacune
on a des débordements parfois on
s'énerve et je crois que c'est arrivé à
tous parfois de pouvoir arriver ou à des
trop de débordements on a tous remarqué
que c'était pas super utile pour pour se
faire entendre
elle est on va terminer cette semaine
est la fusion avec le parti communiste
qui a un nouveau chef et c'est un député
fabien roussel 49 ans député du nord élu
dimanche dernier lors du 38e congrès du
parti il succède au sénateur de paris
pierre laurent est la faucille ont le
choix de fabien roussel c'est le choix
d'un nouveau parti communiste alors
c'est une question un peu compliqué à la
place où je suis à la fois je le dit
avant je moi je suis une parlementaire
et dans mon groupe nous ne sommes pas
bureau politique bise du parti
communiste donc on est nous sommes des
députés des parlementaires élus chacun
dans nos circonscriptions et donc ça
c'est je crois notre force notre unité
en suit la ligne de fax de l'horreur
dans les airs et en tant que militante
j'ai exprimé des avis différents une
orientation différente de celle de
fabien roussel
nous avons eu ce tendre congrès sa ligne
l'a emporté c'est quelque chose que je
respecte les communistes qui ont choisi
je suis attaché à cette démocratie
interne et donc moi je souhaite
sincèrement bonne chance à fabien je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le la
réinvention que j'appelais de mes voeux
mais en tout cas je lui souhaite
sincèrement bonne chance merci je vous
en prie merci à la fission merci
thibault et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]